[Music]
bears congrats come on this one i wound
up with
don't bring it i said i got it
congratulations
tom brady in the bowels of mercedes-benz
stadium with the lombardi trophy leaving
the locker room hey they just left it
behind so he's gonna he's hey
why not give it to him although although
you could argue he didn't have as much
of a role in earning this one as he's
had in past super bowls chris well
that's all right i mean hey he can't
carry the team all the time the last
three super bowls he's played phenomenal
yeah it was a loss last year but it was
one of the best performances we saw ever
the 28-3 comeback against the falcons
what are they down 10 points to the
great seattle defense and super bowl 49
uh this is what the patriots are right
now then that's the greatness of the
patriots brady executed at the moments
they needed him to execute the most but
he is at the point of his career where
we saw on super bowl sunday he was
managed by the coaching staff you know
third and eighth they run the ball in
the first half they were just like you
know what he threw an interception
earlier we're not gonna let aaron donald
rattle in the pocket or make a dumb
decision or hit him while he's throwing
it we'll run the ball on third and eight
doesn't mean he's not still awesome it
can't lead you to the super bowl but yes
uh either way it was about this
offensive line and this defense for the
new england patriots not this year not
about brady in the passing game
well it just makes you wonder how long
bill belichick is going to tolerate
having a quarterback that he has to
manage a round instead of a guy who's
going to come out and be a gunslinger
and get it done regardless of what the
opposing defense is doing that you can
let throw the ball on third nate and
trust him to get it done for now brady
will still be the guy he'll get a chance
to win number seven in 2019. beyond 2019
though who knows what will happen he's
got one year left on his contract they
may extend it they may not it it all
remains to be seen and you have to
wonder if they would come back and win
it again is that the point where brady
would walk off into the sunset that's
what i say i say next year is the last
year mike i think 2019 will be it for
tom brady and i expect the patriots at
least to be in the final four
well they've been in the final four
every year for the last eight so it
really won't surprise me if they do it
again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports